matemáticas
fue la sola utilización de la palabra
matemáticas y formas de uno temblar en
su haciendo
y eso es por qué
no no comprendemos a veces la magnitud
de las matemáticas
si preguntamos a todas las personas de
la sala sobre cuál fue su materia
favorita
sus años de formación tendremos diversas
respuestas ciencias sociales biología
español incluso educación física
pero ahora si preguntamos cuál fue la
materia que menos les gustó
puedo decir que la mayoría está pensando
en matemáticas o física
y si no en alguna materia que tuviera
que ver con números
y es que porque se hace tan difícil
entender las matemáticas
qué pensarían si les dijeran que podemos
explicar matemáticas con sentimientos
suena raro verdad
dentro del mundo académico no existe una
materia en la cual haya causado tanto
miedo a las personas como para tener una
referencia a esta materia
en matemáticas se conoce como ansiedad
matemática y es ese miedo esa atención
o ese sentimiento de opresión al estar
en frente de una ecuación o de un
problema matemático no importa si es en
la vida académica o en la vida diaria
qué hace tan difícil entender las
matemáticas
eduard frei que en su libro amor y
matemáticas nos regala esta frase el
proceso de crear matemáticas es una
búsqueda apasionada como la creación de
arte o música exige amor y dedicación es
una lucha contra lo desconocido
y contra uno mismo que despierta fuertes
emociones
dentro de las aulas se hace a veces es
muy complicado enseñarle a los alumnos
matemáticas
vamos a decir que la gama de respuestas
a las preguntas pueden ser porque tal
vez el maestro no explica bien tal vez
le caigo mal o incluso porque
simplemente no se me dan
vamos a estar hablando el día de hoy
sobre ciertos conceptos de amores todos
hemos tenido un amor imposible
un amor platónico y un primer amor
vamos y quiero invitarlos el día de hoy
a realizar un viaje casi cósmico vamos a
hablar de matemáticas y si hay alguien
en la sala que sufra ansiedad matemática
tranquilo no vamos a hablar mucho acerca
de nosotros si esté lo más tranquilo
posible o más relajado si en algún
momento de la plática sienten tensión no
sienten esa ansiedad porque estamos
hablando de matemáticas apoyen su
compañero del agua se permitan sentir
ese calor humano que si no los ayudan
menos los vais a ver un poco aunque
vamos a empezar con algunas definiciones
o algunas historias pequeñas para ir
creciendo poco a poco vamos a entender
como las matemáticas se pueden explicar
con sentimientos y vamos a ver cómo
podemos explicar estos tipos de amores
desde el concepto más básico de la
geometría las líneas
amores imposibles las líneas paralelas
las que nunca se conocieron que
estuvieron infinitamente un al lado de
la obra pero nunca pudieron juntarse
todos hemos tenido un amor imposible y
los querían que no pues realmente están
mintiendo y qué mentirosos
es verdad ahora
dentro de las matemáticas las líneas
paralelas zonas que nunca se juntan y de
hecho de eso todos estamos muy
conscientes lo sabemos desde la primaria
las matemáticas nos hacen ir un poco más
allá y dentro de las matemáticas existe
un concepto llamado plano proyectivo en
el cual el cual nos dice que dentro de
las matemáticas
existe otro punto otro lugar en el
infinito en donde todas las líneas se
juntan todas llegan a contarse todas
llegan a un mismo lugar en este caso
podríamos decir que siempre nos quedará
parís y en algún momento de esas líneas
paralelas van a estar juntas en su punto
de fuga
no era tan imposible el amor verdad
imposible hoy será nuestra palabra
favorita
la siguiente historia aludía el primer
amor todos tuvimos ese primer amor
tal vez una mirada tal vez con una
palabra tal vez con alguna este tipo de
detalle
en este caso hablemos de las líneas
tangentes
se encuentran una vez y después se
separan para siempre es de esas veces en
las que te conozco y si te vuelva a ver
me me acuerdo de ti
pero vamos a vamos a ir un poquito más
allá de las matemáticas y vamos a
entender que las matemáticas este punto
que se encuentra ahí la línea tangente
alude al punto en el que se juntan o en
el que tocan la línea de la curva ese
pequeño punto que puede pasar en el que
puede pasar el dedo sin que hayan picos
sin que haya ningún tipo de d
deformidad digámoslo así
es como un primer beso es como un primer
abrazo es como el tocar a una persona
por primera vez que suena bien bonito
verdad
las matemáticas nos enseñan que también
esas líneas pueden ser pueden ser
posibles los encuentros periódicos si
estamos aludiendo a puntos de tangencia
de manera infinita que pueden volverse
cada vez más pequeños e incluso alguna
vez perderse en el infinito
como vemos las matemáticas nos enseñan y
nos permiten crear historias de amor
tristes pero también nos permiten crear
historias de amor felices y con finales
picantes e incluso
[Música]
las matemáticas son en cierta forma una
manera de poder expresar nuestros
sentimientos en el mundo
vamos a hablar de física cuántica
un término que es un tanto desconocido
para todos nosotros porque realmente no
sabemos qué es la física cuántica hoy
quiero hablarles de la ecuación de irak
paul dirac descubrió en los años 20 una
ecuación poderosísima que aludía a dos
conceptos muy grandes de la física la
física cuántica en este caso y la teoría
de la relatividad de alta
estos conceptos o esta ecuación nos
decían cómo se mueven algunas
esta ecuación aquí nos decía cómo se
mueven algunas partículas cuando están a
la velocidad de la luz
en este caso cómo se comportan cuando
electrones viajan casi a la velocidad de
la luz
para entender un poquito más esta
ecuación vamos a decir que si dos
sistemas interactúan el uno con el otro
durante un cierto periodo de tiempo y
luego se separan lo podemos escribir
como dos sistemas separados pero de
alguna manera sutil están convertidos en
un solo sistema aunque se separen y
estén a millones millones de kilómetros
de distancia o muchos años luz se siguen
influyendo el uno sobre el otro aunque
pase tiempo que pase distancia esos dos
átomos que estuvieron unidos en un
principio van a seguir influyendo
directamente en nuestro reloj para
entender esto un poquito de una forma
más convencional hablemos un poco sobre
el amor
ese sentimiento que tenemos hacia
ciertas personas y que cuando estamos
con alguno de ellos o con alguna persona
que amamos pues aprendemos costumbres
aprendemos su forma de ser ante ciertas
situaciones e incluso nos enseñan a
nosotros nos llevamos un cachito de
ellas con nosotros
quiero que piensen en la persona que más
ama en él
cualquier persona aunque ya me esté con
ustedes
a lo mejor la distancia a lo mejor el
tiempo incluso la muerte
el día de hoy
quiero hablarles acerca de una persona
que es especial el libro
el día de hoy quiero hablarles de las
uñas
asuncion se sigue alguna martínez
mejor conocida como chinita y para mí mi
bisabuela
el amor se ve de diferentes
un padre un hijo una madre un hijo un
abuelo un nieto o un nieto a una buena
en este caso
yo perdí a mi abuela hace cinco años
y fue una sensación fue un momento que
realmente fue muy duro para mí
cuando ella falleció víctima de los años
de un corazón muy cansado
muy frágil y muy muy hermoso
algo dentro de mí se desquebrajó y es
que eso es lo que pasa cuando una
persona se va
algo dentro de nosotros es que braga y a
veces no podemos no podemos decir cuál
es el sentimiento cuál es esa esa
presión que sentimos en nosotros
en mi caso
yo sentí que algo dentro de mí se fue
con ella
mucho tiempo y vi llorando y vivi
deprimido haciéndome preguntas y pensar
con mucho
y aunque ustedes no lo crean en las
matemáticas y especialmente en la
ecuación de irak
encontré una respuesta que quiero
compartir con ustedes
mi bisabuela me enseñó a decir gracias a
eso por favor ella fue mi amiga fue mi
confidente ella me cuidó de que yo
estaba pequeño
y yo creo que todos tenemos a alguien
así a alguien a quien nos ha dolido
muchísimo la partida alguien que a veces
ese sentimiento no lo podemos dejar ir
por más que pase el tiempo
cuando yo encontré la ecuación de dirac
qué es una ecuación muy compleja porque
nos habla de mundos muy diferentes y muy
dispersos yo recordé a mi abuela
en este caso porque entendí que a pesar
de la distancia y a pesar del tiempo que
pasara
mientras yo siguiera volviendo a decir
gracias y decir por favor y volviendo a
levantarme todas las mañanas con una
sonrisa y al ser perseverante sin
importar lo duro que es y ella estaría
conmigo
ella siempre estaría en las enseñanzas
que nos dio o en las enseñanzas que me
dijo
en cada uno de los momentos que comparte
con ella
hoy quiero decirles que esa persona que
ustedes piensan que a lo mejor ya no van
a volver a ver por el tiempo por la
distancia o por los disgustos
siempre pasa con ustedes
independientemente de lo que pase y de
la cantidad de años luz como es la
ecuación que estén entre ustedes
cuando pasan situaciones de este tipo
nosotros nos ponemos a pensar
en qué es lo que al final
queremos dejar
el día de hoy yo quiero que entienden
que somos un solo una sola partícula que
cuando nosotros nos vayamos de aquí que
cuando nosotros salgamos vamos a hacer
partículas diferentes cada quien va a ir
a un mundo distinto con sus diferentes
fuerzas con diferentes momentos y con
diferentes tiempos
pero de una manera muy sutil
vamos a seguir interconectados
como decía mi compañero anterior
acerca de la luz que se llevarán vengo a
entregarles un regalo el regalo de ver
las matemáticas con otros ojos
el regalo de ver que las matemáticas se
pueden expresar con sentimientos
el regalo de entender que las personas
que aman siempre van a estar con ustedes
sin importar la distancia o el tiempo
y quiero decirles un pequeño secreto
yo era pésimo en matemáticas
y aludiendo una de las respuestas
anteriores simplemente no se me daban
pero encontré maestros en el mundo
académico que me enseñaron a ver las
matemáticas desde otro punto de vista a
entender que las matemáticas son más que
números
a comprender que las matemáticas son la
naturaleza misma
si ustedes quieren decirle alguna vez a
una persona
que la quieren
le pueden decir que lo aman
pero si quieres decirle que lo aman a
pesar del tiempo de la distancia y de
los momentos que pasan entre ustedes
pueden decirle que lo quieren como la
ecuación de drake
puede haber dos tipos de reacciones
diferentes la primera quedan como unos
bohemios completamente inteligentes y
muy hermosos y talentosos y conquistan
el corazón de su amada o formado o la
segunda yo creo que deberían de correr
muy rápido porque les espera un zapatazo
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]